-One of Donald Trump's
former election lawyers
pled guilty and agreed
to cooperate with Georgia
prosecutors in a major blow
to Trump's defense.
Meanwhile, another key player
in the January 6th coup attempt,
Jim Jordan,
as of this taping,
still lacks the votes
to become speaker,
leaving the House GOP in chaos
and causing a backlash
from fellow Republicans
and Fox News pundits.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
There was a major
development today
and one of the four criminal
cases against Donald Trump.
And before we move on,
I just have to say
it's still shocking
that when discussing
a former president
I have to say "one of
the four criminal cases"
and you don't even know
which one I'm talking about.
It could be the election
interference case,
the stolen documents case,
the hush money case,
the Georgia case,
or because the news is so insane
there could be some
other criminal case
you totally forgot about,
like the investigation
into what the hell he's hiding
under that bulky jacket.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like a grandpa
trying to sneak a bunch of kids
into an R-rated movie.
"You haven't seen 'Porky's'
till you've seen it
on the big screen!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, keep it down
while I get us some popcorn."
[ Laughter ]
Well, today's breaking news
involves the election
interference case in Georgia
and specifically one
of Trump's former lawyers
and co-defendants,
Sidney Powell.
You might remember her
from her mugshot,
where she looks like
she just realized
the kid from "The Sixth Sense"
saw her.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, shoot, I'm dead people?"
Or you might remember Powell
from that infamous
press conference
she held with Rudy Giuliani
shortly after the election,
the one where it looked
like A1 steak sauce
was dripping from his skull.
Not that we want to imply
that anything
that comes out
of Rudy's head is A1.
[ Laughter ]
Powell made a bunch
of completely
unhinged claims like these.
-What we are really dealing
with here
and uncovering more
by the day
is the massive influence
of communist money
through Venezuela, Cuba,
and likely China
in the interference
with our elections
here in the United States.
The Dominion Voting systems,
the Smartmatic
technology software,
and the software that goes
in other computerized
voting systems here as well,
not just Dominion,
were created in -- in Venezuela
at the direction of Hugo Chavez
to make sure
he never lost an election.
-Do you think when Trump
was watching that,
he said, "oh, [bleep] it takes
my lawyer a full minute
to get a cap off his water?
[ Laughter ]
Are you seeing this?
It's taking him a full --
a full [bleep] minute."
[ Laughter ]
The other craziest thing
about that clip
is the leopard print.
I mean, she looks like
she's about to raise hell
at a Tampa PTA meeting.
"I don't know why
I would call Rosie Revere
an engineer
when she's clearly a lesbian."
Although maybe she knew the cops
would come looking
for her one day
and her plan was to hide
on a couch from the '80s.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, Sidney Powell claimed
communists in Cuba and China
teamed up with a voting
software company
and a dead Venezuelan dictator
to steal the election.
What really throws me off,
though, is how she says
all those crazy things
in such a flat tone.
It's like if you were
on the subway
and a guy just turned to you
and said,
"Hey, man,
I just wanted you to know...
CIA is reading my brainwaves
and using them to guide
Russian satellites.
Oops, sorry.
This is my stop."
[ Laughter ]
At least Rudy has the decency
to scream
when he's being
a [bleep] nutball.
-There's no Black America!
There's no white America!
There is just America!
Do you think we're stupid?!
You think we're fools?!
Oh, my goodness.
All the networks.
Wow!
All the networks!
-It's never good when you turn
on the TV
and your lawyer is making
the "Oh, God, why?" gesture.
[ Laughter ]
"If the jury says guilty,
I'll just throw my hands
up in the air.
Maybe they'll reconsider.
Oh, God, please give me
a water bottle that opens easy!
[ Laughter ]
Why have You forsaken me
with these tricky bottle caps?
A little bit this way,
a little bit that way.
[ Chuckles ]
A little bit this way,
a little bit -- It's still on."
[ Laughter ]
But Sidney Powell
didn't yell like that.
She had that frightening
monotone, like her voice box
was set to "Sling Blade."
True story.
She asked if Trump could pay her
[as Karl Childers]
in French fried "potaters."
[Normally] Powell also
famously promised to provide
tons of evidence of fraud,
which she never did,
and used one particularly
memorable phrase.
-It's been organized
and conducted
with the help
of Silicon Valley people,
the the big tech companies,
the social media companies,
and even the media companies.
And I'm going to release
the kraken.
-She did...
She did release the kraken.
But unfortunately,
the kraken was also indicted.
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't be surprised
if Sidney Powell was saying
she had a literal kraken
in in her house.
I actually would love
to see a sitcom
about Sidney Powell
and a kraken living together,
like "The Odd Couple"
or "Perfect Strangers."
They could call it
"Kraken Up!"
Well, today, Powell pled guilty
in the case
and agreed to testify against
any of her co-defendants,
which would, of course,
include Donald Trump.
-Sidney Powell,
who was one of
Donald Trump's
fiercest defenders
going back to spinning
conspiracy theories
after the 2020 election,
she's now pleaded guilty
to six charges
related to election subversion.
-As part of this plea deal,
she has agreed that she will
testify in any future trials,
which raises the possibility
that she could testify
against Trump in the future.
-So in exchange, Sidney Powell
agreeing to testify
in all future hearings
and also hand over documents
and evidence
related to this case.
Obviously, given her proximity
to Donald Trump
after the 2020
election, that could be pivotal.
-That's amazing. She's going
to turn over documents
and cooperate
with the prosecution.
Although, how much cooperation
can a person
that insane really provide?
What's she going
to tell prosecutors?
"These are notes from the
meeting I had at the White House
on January 6th
with the president,
Rudy Giuliani,
the kraken, two pegasuses.
Excuse me, two pegasi.
I don't want to --
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to sound
like a crazy person --
and the ghost of Hugo Chavez.
We conspired to steal
the election
and swore an oath of loyalty
by wearing matching
leopard-print sweaters."
And while Trump's legal mess
gets worse in Georgia,
the Republicans political mess
gets worse in DC,
where after more than two weeks
they still can't agree
on a speaker.
The circus has gotten
so humiliating
Republicans are openly
[bleep] on each other.
We say lots of mean things
about Republicans on this show,
but I'm not sure I've ever been
as mean to Republicans
as Republicans are currently
being to themselves.
Take, for example, Fox News
host Brian Kilmeade,
who lashed out at the GOP's
embarrassing antics.
-Ultimately, the Republicans
hope to get a speaker,
and they hope people
will forget by November
that when they had the majority,
they could not --
they could not govern.
Behind the scenes yesterday,
it was all about "vote for me
because let's make a deal."
I got a feeling a whole bunch
of deals were made yesterday.
-It is --
What a carnival of idiots.
It's unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
-First of all, I'm pretty sure
carnival of idiots
was the original title
of "Fox & Friends."
I mean, I don't think I've ever
called Republicans
a carnival of idiots.
I mean,
I've called them unhinged,
oatmeal brain,
insurrectionists,
no neck, mutant freak
mafia goons who look like
they mistook an electric outlet
for a glory hole.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, we do use
that Rudy photo a lot.
But in fairness, we're using it
on our show's merch now.
We're putting it on a shirt
in the NBC store.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, even though Republicans
are all aiming their fire
at each other,
they're still also finding
time to blame Democrats.
Some of them even have
the gall to claim that
because Democrats
did not vote to keep
Republican Speaker
Kevin McCarthy in power,
the whole mess is actually
the fault of Democrats,
an argument so dumb it led to
this contentious back and forth
with CNN anchor
Brianna Keilar.
-The Democrats knew
what they were doing
when they put up 208 votes to
take him out of the speakership.
And that's what created the
current situation that we're in.
So then when we had
a conference meeting --
-They didn't take him
out of the speakership.
I mean, you guys are --
-Sure they did.
-But you guys -- you guys
are the majority, right?
-96% of the votes came from
Democrats, though, Brianna.
I mean -- I mean,
just factually speaking,
there were only
eight Republicans
and there were 208 Democrats.
I mean, 208 Democrats --
-But, sir,
who's in the majority?
-Well, the Democrats were
the majority of that vote.
And when we have --
-No, who's in the majority
in the House of Representatives?
-The Republicans are
in the majority,
but the Democrats provided
the majority of the votes
to take Kevin McCarthy
out of the speakership.
In fact, they provided 96% of
the vote.
-Republicans
provided the key votes.
They're in the majority.
They can provide
enough votes, obviously,
to put a Republican speaker
in place.
-Brianna, the Democrats provided
96% of the votes.
208 Democrats voted to remove
the Republican speaker
of the House.
Eight Republicans
voted to remove
the Republican Speaker
of the House.
-It's some interesting
verbal gymnastics,
I will give you that.
But I want to talk
about the future here.
-What do you mean gymnastics?
I'm just talking
about the facts.
208 Democrats voted.
There were the vast majority
of the vote
to take Kevin McCarthy
out of the speakership.
-Well, I'm talking
about how it works.
-First of all...
I don't know who that guy is,
and I'm not going
to learn his name.
He looks like a stock photo
of a Republican politician.
Is he in Congress,
or is he just the photo
that comes in the frame
at Macy's?
Second, watching this interview
was like
watching a dementia test.
Like, what time is it?
"Well, the clock is round
and the arrows
point at the numbers."
Okay. Yeah,
but what time is it?
"That depends on what number
the arrow is pointing at."
Yeah, but what time is it now?
"Brianna, at this point, we're
just going around in circles
like the arrows
on that clock thingy."
She grilled him so hard
it ended with her
just checkmating him
into silence.
-I'm not sure what -- what
I'm missing here with you,
because 208 Democrats
voted with 8 Republicans
to take the largest
Republican fundraiser
out of the speakership.
This was a pretty
calculated decision
by the Democrats.
I get it --
-It was -- It was a --
Here's why, sir,
because it was a Republican
who filed the motion
to vacate.
-It was. It was a Republican
that had very,
very personal differences
with Kevin McCarthy.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright,
so Jordan lost 22 Republicans.
-Man, he just powered down
like a Roomba
that ran out of batteries.
I haven't seen someone
that deflated
since a tree fell
on the air dancer
at my local car dealership.
Props to Brianna Keilar
for her tough questioning here,
but it shouldn't be just her.
This is how Republicans
should be interviewed on...
-All the networks!
-So now the House remains
without a speaker.
With Jordan failing
after two votes
and still deciding
on whether to hold a third,
some Republicans
have been floating a plan
to empower temporary
Speaker Patrick McHenry
to run the House.
Right now, all McHenry
can really do
as interim speaker is oversee
the election of a real speaker
and gavel the House
in and out of recess.
And knowing
that's all he can do,
he's really going for it
with the gavel.
We've played this clip
a bunch lately,
so prepare yourself
because it is very loud.
[ Explosion ]
This is the state
of the Republican Party.
The faraway frontrunner
for the presidential nomination
is under four indictments
and the House GOP
can't even pick a speaker.
I don't know if they have
a plan for what's next,
but if they want to come up with
one, they better get...
-Kraken.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]